Je vais vous parler de quelque chose qui est dans mon livre
qui j'espère va résonner avec des choses que vous avez entendues,
et je vais essayer de faire les connections, si vous les ratez.
Je commence avec ce que j'appelle le "dogme officiel"
Le dogme officiel de quoi?
Le dogme officiel de toutes les sociétés occidentales.
Il dit ceci:
pour maximiser le bien-être des citoyens
il faut maximiser leur liberté individuelle.
parce que la liberté est intrinsèquement bonne,
de valeur, et essentielle à l'être humain.
Car si les gens ont la liberté,
alors chacun peut agir indépendamment,
faire des choses qui maximiseront notre bien-être,
et personne ne décide à notre place.
Maximiser la liberté, c'est maximiser le choix.
Plus les gens ont de choix, plus ils sont libres,
et plus ils sont libres,
plus ils ont de bien-être.
Ceci est tellement intégré dans la pensée
que personne ne penserait à le remettre en cause.
C'est profondement intégré à nos vies.
Je vais donner quelques exemples de ce que le progrès a rendu possible.
Voici mon supermarché. Pas très grand.
Un mot a propos des vinaigrettes.
175 sortes de vinaigrette dans mon supermarché,
sans compter les 10 sortes d'huile d'olive extra vierge
et les 12 sortes de vinaigre balsamique
pour faire un grand nombre de vinaigrettes maison,
au cas ou vous n'aimeriez aucune des 175 vinaigrettes du magasin.
C'est à ça que ressemble un supermarché.
Puis vous allez au rayon électronique pour chercher une chaîne stéréo --
haut-parleurs, CD, cassettes, tuner , ampli.
Dans ce seul magasin d'électronique,
il y a tant de systèmes stéréo.
Vous pouvez en construire 6,5 millions différentes sortes
avec tous les composants offerts.
Admettez que c'est beaucoup de choix.
Dans un autre domaine -- les communications
Quand j'étais enfant,
vous pouviez avoir tous les services de téléphone que vous vouliez,
du moment qu'ils venaient de Ma Bell.
Vous louiez votre téléphone. Vous ne l'achetiez pas.
Par conséquent, le téléphone n'était jamais cassé.
Ces jours sont révolus.
Nous avons maintenant un choix quasi illimité de téléphones,
en particulier de téléphones cellulaires.
Voici les téléphones cellulaires du futur.
Mon préféré est celui du milieu --
le MP3, le coupeur de poils de nez, et la torche pour les crémes brûlées.
S'il n'est pas encore dans votre magasin,
soyez assurés que ça va venir.
Ceci amène les clients à demander
"Avez-vous un téléphone qui n'en fait pas trop?"
Et de nos jours
la réponse est "Non".
On ne peut pas acheter un tel téléphone.
Pour d'autres aspects de la vie, plus significatifs,
il y a la même explosion de choix.
La santé -- aux Etats Unis vous ne pouvez plus
aller chez le docteur, et le docteur vous dit que faire.
Désormais ,vous allez chez le docteur,
et il vous dit "Bon, on peut faire A, ou B".
"A a ces avantages, et ces risques-ci."
"B a ces avantages, et ces risques-là. Lequel voulez-vous?"
Vous dites:"Que dois-je faire, docteur?"
Il répond: "A présente des avantages et des risques, et B aussi."
"Lequel voulez-vous?"
Vous dites:"Que feriez-vous à ma place?"
Et le docteur répond: "Je ne suis pas vous"
Le résultat, c'est ce qu'on nomme"l'autonomie du patient"
qui semble être une bonne chose.
Mais en réalité, ça déplace le poids de la responsabilité
des prises de décision de quelqu'un qui sait --
le docteur --
vers quelqu'un qui n'y connaît rien et est certainement malade-
et qui donc n'est pas en état de prendre des décisions --
le patient
Il y a un énorme marketing des médicaments
dirigé vers vous et moi,
et qui, si vous y réfléchissez, n'a aucun sens,
puisque nous ne pouvons pas les acheter.
Pourquoi font-ils de la publicité?
Ils veulent que nous appelions notre docteur le lendemain matin
pour demander un changement d'ordonnance.
Quelquechose aussi important que l'identité
est maintenant une affaire de choix,
comme on le voit ici.
Nous n'héritons pas d'une identité, nous devons l'inventer.
Et nous pouvons nous ré-inventer à loisir.
Chaque matin au lever,
vous devez décider quelle personne vous voulez être.
A propos du mariage et de la famille,
il fut un temps ou presque tout le monde
se mariait aussitôt que possible,
avait des enfants dès que possible.
Le seul choix était avec qui,
pas quand, et pas ce que vous faisiez.
De nos jours, tout est à choisir.
J'enseigne à des étudiants brillants,
et je leur donne 20% de travail en moins qu'avant.
Pas parce qu'ils sont moins bons,
pas parce qu'ils sont moins travailleurs.
Mais parce qu'ils sont préoccupés. Ils se demandent,
"Dois-je me marier? Maintenant?
Devrais-je me marier plus tard? Avoir des enfants d'abord? Ou une carrière?"
Ce sont des questions brûlantes.
Et ils doivent y répondre,
quelque soit le travail que je leur donne
et leurs notes.
Ils ont raison. Ce sont des questions importantes.
Le travail -- nous sommes chanceux, comme le disait Carl,
grace à la technologie nous pouvons
travailler à chaque instant depuis n'importe ou --
sauf à l'Hotel Randolph.
(Rires)
Remarquez, il y a un coin,
que je garderai secret, ou le WiFi fonctionne.
Je ne vous le dis pas car je veux pouvoir m'en servir.
Cet incroyable liberté de choix dans le travail
nous impose de choisir
encore et encore et encore,
si vous devons travailler ou pas.
Vous pouvez aller voir votre enfant jouer au foot,
le cellulaire à la hanche,
et le Blackberry sur l'autre hanche,
et l'ordinateur portable sur les genoux.
Et même si ils sont tous éteints,
alors que notre enfant joue au foot,
nous nous demandons,
"Dois-je répondre au téléphone?
Dois-je répondre à ce courriel? Dois écrire cette lettre?"
Et même si la réponse est "non"
ça rend l'expérience du match de foot
très différente.
Partout, les grandes et les petites choses,
les choses matérielles et les modes de vie,
la vie est une question de choix.
Le monde d'avant ressemblait à ça.
Il y avait des choix
mais tout n'était pas matière à choisir.
Le monde d'aujourd'hui est comme ceci.
Est-ce une bonne ou une mauvaise nouvelle?
Le réponse est "oui"
(rires)
Nous savons tous ce que ça a de bon,
je vais vous parler de ce qui n'est pas bon.
Tout ce choix a deux effets
négatifs sur les gens.
Un effet, paradoxalement,
c'est la paralysie, plutot que la libération.
Avec autant de choix,
les gens trouvent difficile de choisir.
Je vous donne un exemple parlant:
une étude sur les investissements volontaires de retraite.
Une de mes collègues a eu accès aux registres d'investissement de Vanguard,
la gigantesque compagnie de fonds mutuels
de 1 million d'employés et 2000 succursales.
Elle a trouvé que
tous les 10 fonds mutuels proposés par l'employeur,
le taux de participation diminue de 2%.
Quand vous offrez 50 fonds -- 10% d'employés de moins participent
que si vous en offrez 5. Pourquoi?
Parce qu'avec 50 fonds,
c'est si dur de choisir
que vous remettez la décision à demain
et à demain, et à demain,
et demain ne vient jamais.
Ça veut dire que les gens devront
manger de la nourriture pour chiens quand ils partiront en retraite
parce qu'ils n'auront pas assez d'économies,
et que la décision est si difficile
qu'ils perdent la contribution de leur employeur.
En ne participant pas, ils perdent 5000 $ par an
donné par l'employeur, qui serait content de participer.
La paralysie est une conséquence de trop de choix.
Et cela rend le monde comme ceci.
(Rires)
Vous voulez prendre la bonne décision si c'est pour l'éternité, non?
Vous ne voulez pas vous tromper sur les fonds mutuels ou la vinaigrette.
Le deuxième effet c'est que si on arrive
à surmonter la paralysie et à choisir,
nous sommes finalement plus insatisfaits
que si nous avions moins de choix.
Pour plusieurs raisons.
Avec un tel choix de vinaigrettes,
si vous en achetez une et qu'elle n'est pas parfaite (laquelle l'est?)
vous imaginez que vous auriez du en choisir une autre
qui aurait été meilleure. Ces alternatives
imaginées vous font regretter votre décision,
et le regret se soustrait à votre satisfaction,
même si vous aviez pris la bonne décision.
Plus il y a de choix, plus il est facile de regretter
les aspects décevants de votre choix.
Deuxièmement, les couts d'opportunité.
Dan Gilbert a dit quelque chose d'important ce matin:
la valeur que nous donnons aux choses
dépend de ce à quoi on les compare.
Si il y a de nombreuses alternatives,
il est facile d'imaginer les bons côtés
des possibilités que vous avez rejetées
et vous rendre moins satisfaits des alternatives que vous avez choisies.
Un exemple. Je m'excuse auprès de ceux qui ne sont pas de New York.
(Rires)
Voici ce que vous êtes supposés penser.
Voici un couple sur les Hamptons.
De l'immobilier très dispendieux.
Superbe plage. Belle journée. Ils ont tout.
Est-ce-que ça pourrait être mieux? "Mince!"
se dit le gars. "C'est Aout.
Tous mes voisins à Manhattan sont partis.
Je pourrais me garer en bas de mon immeuble."
Et l' idée le hante pendant 2 semaines
qu'il rate l'opportunité, chaque jour, d'avoir une bonne place de parking.
Les coûts d'opportunité se soustraient de notre satisfaction
même si ce que nous choisissons est extra.
et plus il y a d'options,
et plus elles sont alléchantes,
plus ça se reflète dans les coûts d'opportunité.
Un autre exemple.
Ce dessin en dit long.
Il montre qu'il faut vivre l'instant présent,
et faire les choses lentement,
et que quand vous choisissez quelque chose
vous choisissez de ne pas en faire d' autres
qui peuvent être très attirantes.
et cela rendra ce que vous faites moins attractif.
3eme point: escalade des attentes.
Cela m'a frappé quand j'ai voulu changer de jean.
J'en porte presque tout le temps.
Il fut un temps ou il n'y avait qu'une sorte,
vous les achetiez, ils ne vous allaient pas bien,
ils étaient très inconfortables,
et si vous les laviez assez souvent,
ils commençaient à être OK.
J'ai voulu changer mes jeans après plusieurs années.
J'ai dit: "Je veux une paire de jeans, voici ma taille."
Le vendeur m'a dit:
"Vous voulez slim fit, easy fit, relaxed fit?"
"Bouton ou fermeture?Lavé à la pierre ou à l'acide?"
"Vous les voulez détendus?"
"Boot cut, fuselé, bla bla bla" Et caetera.
J'étais bouche bée. J'ai dit:
"Je veux le modèle qui avant était le modèle unique."
(Rires)
Il ne savait pas de quoi je parlais.
J'ai passé une heure à essayer tous ces jeans,
et j'ai quitté le magasin, il est vrai, avec les meilleurs jeans que j'ai jamais eus.
Ces choix m'ont permis de faire mieux.
Mais je me sentais moins bien.
J'ai écrit un livre pour essayer de m'expliquer pourquoi.
La raison c'est que avec toutes
ces options à ma disposition,
mes attentes à propos des jeans avaient augmenté.
J'avais de faibles attentes
quand il n'y avait qu'un modèle.
Avec 100 modèle, mon Dieu,
l'un d'eux se devait d'être parfait.
J'ai eu quelque chose de bien, mais pas de parfait.
Comparé à mes attentes,
ce que j'avais était décevant.
Ajouter des options à la vie des gens
augmente leurs attentes
sur la qualité de chaque option.
Ce qui produit moins de satisfaction avec les résultats,
même quand ils sont bons.
Personne dans le monde du marketing ne sait cela.
Sinon, vous ne le sauriez pas vous-même.
La vérité est plutôt comme ça.
(Rires)
Tout était mieux quand c'était pire
parce qu'alors
les gens pouvaient avoir d'heureuses surprises.
De nos jours, nous les citoyens industrialisés,
nous attendons la perfection --
au mieux le truc est aussi bien que vous l'espériez.
Vous ne serez jamais agréablement surpris.
car vos attentes crevent le plafond.
Le secret du bonheur - ce pour quoi vous êtes venus --
c'est d'avoir de faibles attentes.
(Rires)
(Applaudisements)
Je voudrais dire - petit moment autobiographique --
que je suis marié à une femme,
et elle est assez merveilleuse.
Je n'aurais pu faire mieux. Je n'ai pas décidé.
Mais décider n'est pas toujours une mauvaise chose.
Finalement, une conséquence d'acheter des jeans qui vous vont mal
quand il n'y a pas d"autre choix
c'est que quand vous êtes insatisfaits et demandez pourquoi,
à qui la faute, la réponse est claire.
Le monde est responsable. Que faire?
Quand il y a des centaines de jeans differents,
et vous en achetez un qui vous deçoit,
et vous demandez "qui est responsable?"
c'est clair que le répnse est "vous".
Vous auriez pu faire mieux.
Avec des centaines de jeans en exposition,
il n'y a pas d'excuse pour se tromper.
Aussi quand les gens prennent des décisions,
et même si leurs choix sont bons,
ils se sentent déçus,
et ils s'en veulent.
Les cas de dépression ont explosé dans le monde industriel en une génération.
Je crois qu'une cause importante
de cette explosion de dépressions, et aussi de suicides,
c'est que les gens ont des expériences décevantes
car leurs standards sont trop élevés
Et quand ils doivent s'expliquer ces déconvenues,
ils pensent que c'est de leur faute.
Objectivement, nous faisons en général mieux,
et nous nous sentons moins bien.
Laissez moi vous rappeler.
C'est le dogme officiel, celui que nous croyons vrai,
et qui est complètement faux.
Bien sûr avoir du choix c'est mieux que de ne pas en avoir,
mais cela ne veut pas dire que beaucoup de choix est mieux que un peu.
Il y a une quantité magique. Je ne sais pas laquelle.
Je suis convaincu que nous avons dépassé cette limite
du nombre d'options qui augmentent notre bien être.
J'ai presque fini.
Il faut penser à ceci:
Ce qui rend possible tous ces choix possibles c'est l'opulence.
Il y a des nombreux endroits dans le monde,
et nous en connaissons certains,
ou le problème n'est pas d'avoir trop de choix.
Leur problème c'est d'avoir trop peu.
Ce dont je parle est spécifique aux sociétés
occidentales modernes, opulentes.
Ce qui est frustrant et irritant c'est que:
Steve Levitt vous a dit combien un siège auto
cher et difficile à installer n'apporte rien. C'est du gaspillage d'argent.
Je vous dis que ces choix compliqués et onéreux --
non seulement ne servent à rien,
ils font du mal.
Ils nous rendent plus malheureux.
Si nous pouvions envoyer tous ces choix
dans des sociétés ou les gens n'en ont pas assez,
ils vivraient mieux,
et nous aussi.
C'est ce que les économistes appellent une "amélioration Pareto"
La redistribution des richesses rendrait tout le monde plus heureux
parce que l'excès de choix est notre fléau.
Pour conclure. Vous êtes supposés lire ceci,
et, en tant que personne sophistiquée, dire:
"Que sait-il ce poisson?
Vous savez que rien n'est possible dans un bocal à poissons".
Imagination appauvrie, vue myope du monde,
et c'est ce que j'avais compris la première fois,
Mais plus j'y pensais et plus je comprenais
que le poisson sait quelque chose.
Car la vérité c'est que si vous faites exploser le bocal
pour tout rendre possible, vous n'obtenez pas
la liberté mais la paralysie.
Si vous faites exploser le bocal,
vous diminuez la satisfaction.
et vous augmentez la paralysie.
Tout le monde a besoin d'un bocal à poisson.
Celui-ci est sûrement trop petit --
même pour un poisson, et sûrement pour nous.
Mais l'absence d'un bocal métaphorique conduit à la misère,
et, je le suspecte, au désastre.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)